Stephen you have a story credit as well
as a screenplay credit for upon
sacrifice was this aspect the script for
you yeah Toby approached me and said
that this was a passion project of his
and so basically I began with the life
of Bobby Fischer as it is documented in
you know various places and if the
process then was just deciding what
stories to tell and what not to tell
what to keep out and so it's just
finding the because you've got this
natural wonderful film ending which is
the game itself and the victory of Bobby
the underdog against Boris so it was in
a sense of the good guy as well so you
have that wonderful ending that you then
have to sort of go back and find the
stepping stones to get there that makes
it an effective story now forgive me I
mean this as a compliment so here we go
so many Hollywood writing careers seem
to taper off as someone gets older but
yours seems to be going up and up and up
what did you tribute this I think I just
keep doing stuff you know and I think
it's important to do stuff that you're
interested in as well and so you know
and something like this comes along you
can really enjoy it because you're
telling a true story and and if you're
doing stuff you love it's going to show
I think when a studio hires you to write
a screenplay is there information that
they provide to you are they giving you
you know set pieces that they say must
be in it rarely I mean usually it
depends what it is if you're adapting a
book then there will be reasons why the
studio loves the book and it's sort of
folly to then go around those reasons do
you know what I mean I mean there's
something that was obviously attracted
the people have chosen that book to it
and and you you know you would be
foolish not to address that if it's a
real life like Bobby then you know there
are certain events and incidents that
define that
person's life and so you would go for
that but I think very rarely does the
studio say you must have this scene whom
from the studio approaches you with a
writing assignment in this case it was
Toby because Toby was the driving force
behind this because it was his passion
project so he wasn't so much as a very
typical studio commissioned it was more
I remember getting the phone calls and
just saying this is what we want to do
we want to do this life and then I did
some reading and just thought he was
fantastic but even in other situations
is it is it normally a producer or
someone that's producing always okay do
you think writing for US audiences
varies from writing for UK audiences yes
in a way I think if you well there's two
things if you're writing American
characters it's different because I
think American characters and American
people are more verbal they they're more
communicative than British or European
because you could you could write a
scene on a train in the u.s. not that
many people travel by train in the US
but sit down on a train where two people
would talk to each other strangers in
the UK you'd have to have a reason and
so I think there is a difference in
terms of dialogue the way that people
communicate we share that with each
other is very different interesting how
about writing the hero versus the
antihero well everybody loves the unti
here about it's very funnily enough it's
very difficult to give you everybody
says you must give you a hero floors but
it's very difficult to give them real
floors when you try and give them
something that really is not good people
show ever they always want them to be
too tough you know too angry too bitter
and all of those things are sort of
vaguely attractive so giving your hero
genuine floors is quite brave like Bobby
Fischer has many flaws thank you thank
you stay right